Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
I don't really want to make a video today, but it's Tuesday, so.
Hank, when we were growing up in Orlando, Florida
It always felt to me like we were all just visiting
Like we were all just there for the theme parks
whether to visit them or work in them.
And even today, when people ask me where I'm from,
I usually say Alabama, even though I didn't move there until I was 14
For a long time I believed that because I never felt fully at home in Orlando,
that no one else could either, but of course that's just
narcissism. In the 24 years since I have left
Orlando has become a great city
People have made it an awesome home town by growing
deep roots there - including a strong Latino community
and a vibrant LGBT community.
Both of which have achieved so much with love,
and activism in the face of a long history of
violence and discrimination.
And now, 49 people, killed in a gay club in Orlando.
I-I don't know, Hank. I don't know what to say
I don't know if I have anything constructive to say.
I do think it's valuable to listen to people who've been directly affected
by the shootings in Orlando.
I've put some reading in the doobly-doo.
I was particularly moved by the partner of Leroy Valentin Fernandez
who wrote: "You will always be my baby,
and I will always love you."
And by the brother of victim Amanda Alvear,
who said: "She wouldn't want anyone to spread hate for
her, she would want them to spread more love."
And by victim Luis Wilson-Leon's friend Daniel,
who said: "He'd been dealing with hate all his life.
We all have. I have.
He never retaliated with hate."
Aside from that, Hank, I really just want to share
with you the names of the people who were murdered.
I think we should hear their names as much as possible.
Last night Orlando showed what a great city it is when
thousands of people came our to memorialize the dead
and to stand with their friends and families.
Let us also stand with them, by listening to them,
by listening to those who loved them,
and by remembering them.
Edward Sotomayor Jr.
Stanley Almodovar III
Luis Omar Ocasio-Capo
Eric Ivan Ortiz-Rivera
Peter Ommy
Juan Ramon Guerrero
Luis Vielma
Kimberly Morris
Eddie Justice
Darryl Roman Burt II
Deonka Deidra Drayton
Alejandro Barrios Martinez
Anthony Luis Laureano Disla
Jean Carlos Mendez Perez
Franky Jimmy Dejesus Velazquez
Amanda Alvear
Martin Benitez Torres
Luis Daniel Wilson-Leon
Mercedez Marisol Flores
Xavier Emmanuel Serrano Rosado
Gilberto Ramon Silva Menendez
Simon Adrian Carrillo Fernandez
Oscar Aracena-Montero
Enrique Rios Jr.
Miguel Angel Honorato
Javier Jorge-Reyes
Joel Rayon Paniagua
Jason Benjamin Josaphat
Cory James Connell
Juan Rivera Velazquez
Luis Daniel Conde
Shane Evan Tomlinson
Juan Chevez-Martinez
Jerald Arthur Wright
Tevin Eugine Crosby
Leroy Valentin Fernandez
Jonathan Antonio Camuy Vega
Jean Nives Rodriguez
Rodolfo Ayala-Ayala
Brenda Lee Marquez McCool
Akyra Monet Murray
Yilmary Rodriguez Solivan
Christopher Andrew Leinonen
Angel Candelario-Padro
Frank Hernandez
Paul Terrel Henry
Antonio Davon Brown
Christopher Joseph Sanfeliz